politique française dans un peu plus de
trois heures à minuit en même temps que
sera clos le dépôt des candidatures
s'ouvrira officiellement la campagne
électorale pour le premier tour des
élections législatives
une campagne commencé d'ailleurs depuis
longtemps déjà avec de nombreuses
réunions politiques au cours des
dernières 48 heures notamment demain
première journée donc de cette campagne
officielle monsieur françois mitterrand
répondra dans une conférence de presse
aux propos tenus par le président de la
république au cours de sa dernière
intervention à la télévision
nous avons présenté hier soir deux
candidats parmi ceux que l'on peut
appeler les fils à papa de la politique
sans que cette expression est quoi que
ce soit désobligeant
il s'agissait de patricia revenus et de
ladislas poniatowski voici ce soir
gilbert mitterrand fils de françois et
jean louis debré fils de michel ministre
d'état chargé de la défense nationale
candidat dans la 7e circonscription du
pas-de-calais âgé de 28 ans marié jean
louis debré est assistant à la faculté
de droit de sous et romieu franches
montagnes et des sons un peu
physiquement vous ressembler un peu à
votre père est ce que ça vous aide
pour vous en ce moment on perd ça n'est
pas une question une bonne appréciation
si j'avais été un fils à papa comme on
dit croyez moi j'aurais trouvé ses
conceptions plus facile bien sûr je ne
dis pas que ça le sert je ne dis pas
nécessairement que ça sert de s'appeler
le devrais je demande qu'une seule chose
c'est qu'il soit connu par beaucoup de
monde le plus bas possible qu'on puisse
apprécier ses qualités
c'est la première campagne électorale la
première campagne électorale que je fais
effectivement
est-ce que vous avez l'impression aux
débuts de commettre des erreurs que vous
avez dû rectifier a commis beaucoup on
va par exemple je ne voudrais pas vous
le dire la folie tir sinon les
adversaires s'en servirait ses 82 chez
marie
problème si la campagne est donc prêt ça
uniquement de contacts humains de porte
à porte
comment vous faites pour les commerçants
vous leur laissez votre adresse
oui je donne ma carte de visite et
l'adresse et je lui envoie un petit mot
lendemain pour les remercier de m'avoir
reçu après avoir vendu d'articles divers
les bottes et une machette
je les jeunes et je vous remercie je le
dise faible ou un petit porte-clefs à
mon effigie
vous croyez que c'est important ça ça
souvenir pour l'enfant c'est tout sauf
que justement compétences pour y attirer
puis vous êtes obligé de boire beaucoup
dans une journée une boîte de l'eau je
me moque de loger un grand père qui est
président de la ligue antialcoolique
alors il faut avec son petit-fils reste
dans la famille qu'est ce que disent et
j'en veux je suis venu à me fait le coup
dur j'ai vu commerçants aussi aller à
l'urgence le portement parlé avec le
chat encore dans une paroisse a cure et
devra s'abstenir
le style décontracté et plaît à certains
ce n'est pas tout le monde
vous avez dû mettre un peu d'eau dans
votre vin j'ai dû mettre un gilet j'ai
dû mettre une cravate
gilbert mitterrand le fils du premier